Scot Osterweil: With that I want
to turn it over to Jim Paradis,
the Robert Metcalfe professor of
Writing and Media Studies, who's
going to introduce our today's
speaker. So, Jim.
Jim Paradis: Thanks, Scott.
Welcome to the Comparative Media
Studies colloquium at MIT. I
think there's a number of people
from MIT and outside of MIT. I'm
Jim parody a faculty member of
Comparative Media Studies and
Writing. Our talk this afternoon
is creating space for balance
indigenous knowledge and Western
science -- two-eyed seeing --
environmental justice and media.
Our featured speaker is Patricia
Saulis. This year is MLK
visiting scholar, also executive
director of the Maliseet Nation
Conservation Council, and a
member of the Maliseet tribe of
indigenous people whose lands
lie along the St. John/Wolastoq
River and its watershed along
both sides of the US and Canada.
River empties into the Bay of
Fundy. So very tremendous River.
Miss Saulis is an experienced
tribal policy administrator, and
environmentalists and
Educational Planner. A recording
of this talk will be posted
Friday at the CMS website to aid
seeing has been a contemporary
concept, but of two indigenous
Mikmaq elders in Cape Breton
Canada through the use of
indigenous oral tradition.
Elders, Dr. Albert Marshall and
Dr. Nina Marshall have
participated in many recordings
of their concept and teaching.
Their appearances at conferences
across Canada and the US have
provided many venues to share
their work. In our presentation
this afternoon, Patricia will
feature clips of the two elders
speaking and provide some
perspective on how their work
could be brought forward in
discussions of environmental
justice, and media. Patricia,
welcome, and it's all yours.
Patricia Saulis: Woliwon,
Professor Paradis and I just
want to say, kwe, hello, ni'n
teluisi is Patricia Saulis. I am
from Tobique First Nation, which
is a Maliseet community in
Brunswick, Canada. And it's a
great honor to be with you here
this evening. And I look forward
to to where discussion, I did
prepare a PowerPoint that I will
ask for it to be brought up so
that I can share some of my
ideas and thoughts with you this
evening.
So I had
had the idea that I needed a new
mantra. And and that new mantra
is creating space for balance.
And
in regards to indigenous
knowledge and Western knowledge
in the two-eyed seeing approach
and how it can apply to
environmental justice and media.
I thought that this was you
know, a very apt opportunity to
be able to share some of the
insights from two of the elders
who have been leading the CO
creation and co learning process
that is enabled through adopting
the two-eyed seeing approach. In
order to, I guess get started on
my presentation, I would ask for
the next slide.
Scot Osterweil: Andrew, it's not
advancing.
It's not advancing is showing on
mine is the second
Andrew Whitacre: among the
second slide on mine,
Scot Osterweil: yeah, you may
need to unshare and try again.
It depends on how you selected
the window when you shared your
Andrew Whitacre: I see, I see.
Unknown: Um
Andrew Whitacre: does that show
any different?
Unknown: Yes. acknowledgments.
Okay, good.
Yes.
Patricia Saulis: Thank you,
Scot. Thank you so much. Um, so
as as part of our protocol, we
often start with our
acknowledgments. And so in my
acknowledgement, I'd like to
give things to the MIT graduate
program and Comparative Media
Studies. And Professor James
Paradis, as my host, faculty
member, as well as the institute
community and equity office,
that the MLK Visiting Scholar
Program is a part of it also
like to give thanks for the MIT
Native American student
association and alumni, as well
as the MIT American Indian
Science and Engineering Society,
as well as supportive
colleagues, friends and family,
who are supporting me and of
course, helping me to achieve
what I can and this wonderful
year of, although it's, it's
virtual, I'm still very, very
glad and grateful to to be a
part of this program. Next
slide, please. Further
acknowledgments, as per the
protocol is to give thanks to
the waters, the ground, the
trees, the plants, the crawlers,
the swimmers, the winged ones,
the two legged and the four
legged, as well to give things
for our levels of creation,
which is, of course, above us,
below us, and what is on the
surface, as well to acknowledge
and give things to the seen and
unseen. As well as our
ancestors, all of our ancestors,
past, present, and future. I'd
also like to give
acknowledgement to the spirit of
songs, dances, languages, and
our dreams. And being the one of
the MLK scholars, I feel it's
very important to always draw
upon the legacy of Dr. King. And
the very, the very essence of so
much of his wisdom is based on
many of the notable quotes that
have been captured as part of
that legacy. And I'd like to
share just one with you as a way
to ground this work and in the
work that I do. He said, make a
career of humanity. commit
yourself to the noble struggle
of equal rights. It will make a
greater person of yourself a
greater nation of your country,
and define our world to live in.
Next slide please.
As well, I would like to provide
the
acknowledgement
to
the land acknowledgement, MIT
land acknowledgement. MIT
acknowledges indigenous peoples
as the traditional stewards of
the land, and the enduring
relationship that exists between
them and their traditional
territories. the land on which
we sit is the traditional
unceded territory of the
Wampanoag nation. We acknowledge
the painful history of genocide
and forced occupation of their
territory, and we honor and
respect the many diverse
indigenous peoples connected to
the land on which we gather from
time immemorial.
Next slide please.
As well, I want to give
acknowledgement to the protocol.
And as I've outlined many
indigenous nations follow many
levels of protocol, such as
ceremonial protocol, spiritual
protocol, language protocol,
cultural protocols. All
community protocol, inter nation
protocol, an interpersonal
protocol. Acknowledging
protocol, knowing protocol and
honoring protocol is an
essential element to
establishing respectful
relationships. relationship
building on protocol is a
culturally sensitive and
appropriate way of demonstrating
care and concern for well being.
Following protocol is meant to
ensure inclusion, gratitude and
acceptance at the forefront of
recognizing the spirit of all
that is brought together and
provides protection from what
may be negative.
Next slide, please.
So, delving into the subject at
hand, too, I'd seen I did just
want to give a little bit of
context before we also delve
into some of the YouTube
references that I'm going to
share with you tonight. Two-eyed
seeing approach, in redressing
systemic discrimination and
environmental racism and
injustice is based on the idea
that there is a combined vision
necessary to understand the
plate of life today. Some will
list of elders or mela seated
elders have noted that what
happens to were relatives, the
four legged swimmers, the
fliers, the crawlers, those seen
and unseen will happen to us to
what humans are doing to their
surroundings is having a
devastating and lasting impact
to life. Climate change does
exist, and that it is man made.
Climate change is not only about
impacts to humans, but to all
life and that is a story about
life and death. And there is
great grief, sorrow and anger in
the telling of this story.
Further, that we understand that
humans are but one of our but
only one species of 8.7 million.
It is going to take a
reconnecting a vision between
two competing worldviews to
fully understand where we are at
and what needs to change,
knowing how to use the best of
both. Next slide please. So, at
this point, I'm going to share
with you our two elders that I'm
going to reference in the next
part of the presentation. Can we
play the first then second link
please?
Albert Marshall: [Untranslated]
in English, it means that
to be mindful of
maintaining that interconnection
and your dependency within with
our with all of creation. We
have to do it on a daily on a
daily ritual basis. Yes, let's
use the word prayer. We use that
format of not just acknowledging
but expressing our appreciation
to what he has given us. And and
after to remind ourselves at
what our responsibilities are of
ensuring that you're in our
little shorts tea here in the
physical plane. We have to
somehow we have to find a way
and be mindful as to how we go
about exercising our inherent
responsibilities of ensuring
that no action that we that we
will take will never compromise
the ecological integrity of the
area, nor compromise the
cleansing capacity of the
system. Because the overall
objective is to ensure that the
next seven generations will also
have the same opportunities as
we have and hopefully better
opportunities than we have. I've
not just been able to sustain
themselves and harvest the gifts
from the creator but also be
able to enjoy and learn from
from from from her. Just like
what our answers I've learned
from
Murdena Marshall: I'm Murdena
Marshall. I'm a retired
Associate Professor, my
grandmother and great
grandmother. I was born in 1942.
And what caught my
eye left what caught my eye at
one year
and move to the big
centralization party, that the
federal government [...] and I
was caught up in that. Well,
when you're invited to a party,
you're not going to say no. I
grew up here was educated at the
day school, Indian day school
until grade nine I think. And
then I went to Arichat for a
year or two, then I transferred
to St. Joseph's convent in
Mabou. After high school, I got
married, and everybody was gone
home to marry me because I
wasn't yet pregnant. My father
was delighted when I asked him,
Holy mackerel, when he said was
in those days, you only need
high school to survive and get
married as soon as you can.
before you're in the valley way.
I decided to go back to school
and I went to teachers college
to have that early childhood
program. But I when I found out
you cannot teach in a regular
school program with that
certificate, I think donate
three or something like that.
then moved on to UMB. And there
I received my Bachelor of
Education degree.
And then from there, I moved to
I went on to our for and
received my Master's in
administration, Social Planning
and social policy. And from
there, I realized the greatest
need for Eskasoni was to trapped
the language to make it static,
so it doesn't erode any longer.
So I went to St. Thomas
University and graduated with a
with the certificate program of
teaching the average indigenous
languages and training teachers.
And then I work for the went to
work for university of CBU and
was there for 18 years until I
took sick. I have always been
concerned about the language.
I decided to
prepare my education and there
is working towards and around
language. And I've been doing
that. Although my my Masters is
in administration, at the
University where I work, that
wasn't a discipline I was in. So
I first year I did curricula.
And the next year after I made
the curriculum, they asked me to
teach
so I taught
Yeah, but that's again, that was
so big.
I had five classes
to fulfill the need. It drained
me out of my own energy and out
of my own spunk at them brag and
I'm the Savior of the world. But
I was able to open some of their
minds. When I left they replaced
me with three people tested
drove we met we met I haven't
left Cape Breton much except for
education. I enjoy Cape Breton.
I enjoy the water. I was born
that far from the water right
because couple hundred feet in a
bottle was lift near water. And
when I go somewhere like Calgary
or and there's no water around I
feel very uncomfortable and
unable to sleep and no as I
missed that air, not the waves,
but I missed that air coming
from the sea. But papered has
been my favorite spot in the
world. Not having so much
choices but the places where I
have been up Excuse me. Oh,
always draws me back to paper,
but at the hospitality and the
familiarity of the place and We
lived in Boston for a while, I
thought mostly about Cape Breton
too. But we came home because I
wanted my children to speak
their own language and to
recognize the most precious
thing in me my life. And that's
family. I want them to
experience they're on Send now
girls and cousins and however
they're, they're connected to
them and I give my greatest
credit to my grandfather. He was
my mentor. Even when I was into
marriage, he was still my
mentor, and my aunt Jessie
Jadore the medicine woman. Those
to her to bring this impact in
my life. And my other aunt and
Catherine, who taught me the
hieroglyphics and another on
taught me how to tell stories
and preserve legends and all
that why English has no
preposition, it has no word
order, it has no gender. There
are certain pronouns that you
use contant- consistently. And
there's five tenses. So it's a
that's a [...] the five tenses.
They are the past person to
future, but they're missing out
on the healing tense. And there
is stuff on the spiritual tense.
And they're both so appealing
when you were a little kid. And
you have no television or radio
or a [...] or anything like
that. You you listen to stories,
and you tend to sit around the
fire after supper and everything
well innovate while or there is
no such thing as suffered dinner
or breakfast. You eat when
you're hungry. Your body your
body dictates your your your you
eat just you don't dictate your
body. And so when you want to go
to the bathroom, we don't wait
for the beep or [...], see one
for so we have two stories,
different people would come in
in the evenings and visit and
tell stories. And I received a
lot of stories from listening to
my own grandparents and my own
aunts and uncles, the stars,
were your guiding point.
Do the constellations for your
calendar
to look up in the sky who know
what season two By the way, the
constellations are arranged.
They're also your guides for
travel and stuff like that. Now
take for instance, the
constellation of the dipper. Now
that's a long stretch to teach
you seasons of the year, months
of the year. And how out the
bear resituated is we tell you
what time of year it is. Winter
is late spring or mid summer,
beginning of fall. Oh, by the
way, the constellations are
raised, and the equinoxes and
the salts play an important role
in determining the movement of
the earth.
So you sort of know these
stories
because you do them through
people telling them but as you
grow up, you don't know really
what why they tell you the
stories until you yourself began
to take up an interest in in the
sky or night stories or
astronomy. Then you begin to
piece these pieces together
these stories attached to this
constellation and vice versa. I
have no one to think but my
family these doors didn't.
Didn't come automatically. It
was through experience and you
remember in because you can't
when you when a story is told to
you in this interest and it
turns to pick it out in your
mind. No, it'll stay there
engraved there.
Patricia Saulis: So, those two
elders Dr. Albert and Dr.
Murdena Marshall, along with
Cheryl Bartlett work through
Cape Breton University in
Sydney, Nova Scotia, Canada to
create the Institute for
integrative science and health.
And that Institute lasted from
2006 to 2012 The institute
offered a science degree
program. Since prefer, Professor
Bartlett has retired and the
program has transitioned into
another department, there is
still a growing segment of
science faculty and universities
across Canada that have sought
to adopt the two-eyed seeing
learning approach to enrich
their solely Western based
programs. As a way of sharing
this with MIT, I am hoping that
there that there are those
amongst you that seek a similar
vision of learning that can
create not only a higher level
of success, but also a greater
degree of connectivity and
learning that will enable
enables superior learning
paradigm development and
research in creating a better
world for all. Next slide,
please. So we have another two
segments on YouTube. If we could
play one, then the next, Andrew.
Sure.
Cheryl Bartless: That's how it
started. Communities, the elders
were concerned that there were
not any students from their
communities going into the
sciences.
Albert Marshall: Two-eyed seeing
really, he has to be your
guiding principles as to how one
should live. While you are here
on these on the on the shirt.
Cheryl Bartless: Two-eyed seeing
as brought to us by elder Albert
Marshall Miꞌkma Elder Eskasoni
is recognizing that there are
different ways of looking at the
world. And maybe two of those
ways are the western scientific
way. And the indigenous peoples
are the Aboriginal peoples way.
And that two-eyed seeing refers
to finding the strength in both
of those, the Western and the
indigenous. And mindfully
bringing those strengths
together. drawing upon the deep
understandings that they
represent the strengths of each
and bringing them together to
work together to go forward on
this planet. Together,
Murdena Marshall: I feel that
what we learned as First Nations
people in your own identity meet
what is valuable. I also believe
that the cost has been brought
on by Europeans is also valuable
in today's world. And you try to
bring those together and look at
it through two, I'd seen that
both are very valuable. And both
can be can be achieved.
Albert Marshall: Our airs are
poisoned, our rivers are
poisoned, our forests are pretty
much gone. And the animals are,
are extinct even as we speak.
With this two-eyed seeing, we
very quickly realized and see
that science, science is not
going to save the environment or
the natural world, but rather to
greater change every change of
attitude change change of
mindsets,
Cheryl Bartless: I see the
strengths of Western science as
being the ability to look at the
physical world. See the patterns
within it and take those
patterns apart and find the
mechanisms. We're trying to
search for the mechanisms that
that bring those patterns into
existence. And then on the basis
of that reconstructed
understanding, try to improve
upon our material existence
often. For humans in this world,
I see the strengths of the
indigenous peoples on the other
hand of also seeing the patterns
in the world. But rather than
taking them apart, to
reconstruct them, it's more of a
working of patterns within
patterns. In other words, a
weaving of yourself and your
understandings into the world in
which you live. I think one of
the most exciting and useful
ways to teach science would be
to use one of the methods from
science itself, which is the
Compare and contrast. Why can't
we educate our science students
as to what the mainstream way of
doing science is? and compare it
and contrast with another way of
doing science from an indigenous
perspective, why can't we put
them side by side and use them
to help students develop a
better understanding of what
mainstream science is? And what
other perspectives on science
are? That's a scientific method
compare and contrast.
Albert Marshall: Basically, the
the education system has taught
us to, to observe every
knowledge we get without
actually, without actually
questioning it or looking at it
from another perspective.
Cheryl Bartless: Why do we think
that we can teach by focus on it
on the one thing when the whole
of human consciousness is not a
focus on one thing, it's always
a back and forth a scanning of
the environment and a compare
and contrast, a past and a
future within the present.
Murdena Marshall: With me, Mark
identity. As I was growing up, I
didn't know any other identity.
Because I was being trained in
magma. I was trained in
language, and in the language
embedded all of your your are
your oral traditions, all your
moral, and all your everyday
life, your history is involved
in it. Because when you went to
bed at night, without the
competition of television
attire, and everything else, you
had stories, he has stories of
what your own history, he has
stories about, about everything
that is required to make you
into a better human being.
Cheryl Bartless: And part of the
struggle of anybody, I don't
think it matters who you are, is
to ask yourself and to learn who
am I. So if an educational
system ignores part of who who
you think you are, simply
because it doesn't include your
people's understandings as for
example, if the science
curriculum does not include any
of the understandings that
Canada's Aboriginal peoples have
with respect to the land that
they've occupied for thousands
of years, then that ability to
develop a well balanced and deep
understanding of who you are, as
a young Aboriginal in Canada
today is going to be denied
Albert Marshall: Our journey
here. It's not meant for one,
one perspective, or one
consciousness to get us to, when
we all need each other. So the
the lessons that we are kind of
put forth now is pretty new to
our young people. It couldn't be
much more expedient, if we can
take the best, whatever tools
the right man has brought forth.
And the tools, what our
forefathers had left us with.
Murdena Marshall: This two-eyed
seeing is valuable. When you
when you pick from the tool from
you, when you pick from two
worlds, and try to call join
call join those two is I find it
very difficult, but I know it
has to be done. I know you can I
can. I can crawl into my culture
and say, Oh, that's all I need
to survive in this world. I also
know that you need the white
man's education to to survive in
this world and be happy. And and
I think the white man also needs
me to what I have to offer.
Cheryl Bartless: We have a
challenge ahead of us to bring
to the attention of that
educational system. The Western
way of looking at things is but
one way
Albert Marshall: Paraphrasing
Chief Dan George saying, w
should take the instruments of
the white man. He's taught u
and he said education bette
when he cooperated with ours. S
we can create a better world fo
everyone
Patricia Saulis: So as we know
that there are many who want to
utilize two-eyed seeing as a
tool that can help themselves
and others understand the
indigenous worldview, and how it
can help create a better path to
environmental justice,
indigenous justice and human
justice. There is a strong
connection being developed
between two-eyed seeing and
seeing more equity in relations
between all life on Earth. I am
going to share with you two
practitioners, both indigenous,
both in two different parts of
this country, both striving to
use this tool in their work, and
both present their stories and
thoughts based on the two-eyed
seeing. Yep. Okay.
Evan Tlesla Adams: Good evening.
My name is Evan Tlesla Adams and
I'm so happy to present some
ideas to you tonight, around the
the very simple concept of
two-eyed seeing which most of us
are, are lucky enough to have
these two masts were collected
here in the north of British
Columbia, one is in the Louvre
in Paris and one is it the
Canadian Museum of civilization
and get you know, and one is
blind and one is sighted and
might represent maybe us looking
at you or looking forward and
back. Now this is a fish it's
called a sole, you've probably
eaten it. It's very humble fish.
It can look in two directions at
once. It's a it's a bit unlike
human beings who have binocular
vision, but they usually look
those eyes look in the same
direction from but from slightly
different positions. So is
two-eyed seeing or looking
forward and looking back
whimsical? Is it avant garde? Is
it post colonial? Maybe it's
part of being the pluralistic,
multicultural success story of
being in modern Canada, maybe
this is reconciliation, and
maybe two-eyed seeing is the
ability to look inward and
outward at once. Maybe we can
self reflect, maybe we must look
ourselves in the eye, see the
truth and be able to sleep at
night. And maybe to eyed seeing
is hopeful or beautiful or it's
the idea of balance the idea of
getting back to optimism and to
beauty. Maybe two-eyed seeing is
about love and family and
togetherness, strength,
acceptance, maybe it's about
prosperity, of both, or of all.
Now two-eyed seeing is a concept
that exists in indigenous
culture. And there is a very
famous academic, Mr. Albert
Marshall who talks about
two-eyed seeing as learning to
see with the strengths of each
other and together looking one
eye with the strengths of
indigenous knowledge is in ways
of knowing and with the other
eye, the string of Western
knowledges and ways of knowing
and that together we can look
forward. So here's another way
of seeing 1492 two eyes coming
together. Christopher Columbus
arriving in the off an island in
the Caribbean, he was lost
looking for India. And that
arrival set off a great time or
a period of exploration for
Europeans. This is a painting of
Captain Cook when he was killed
by Native Hawaiians on the Big
Island of Hawaii in 1779. And
aboard that ship was a
midshipman named George
Vancouver. George Vancouver came
to the coast of British
Columbia, again and again and
again. Here's his is a portrait
drawn when he came to my
mother's village 1792 Cortez
Island, of course, my mother
hadn't been born yet. She was
born about a kilometer from
here. And so for me, Captain
Vancouver is very real. And we
have very many stories about
those. This is my great
grandfather, Tom Charlie Adams,
who was born in 1860. This
picture was taken of him in 1930
when he entered hospital with
dementia. And he's alive. He's
blind. So he doesn't he doesn't
he didn't I hear open his eyes
as he walked about. And he lost
his vision to smallpox. This is
Canada. This is Canada 1867. It
looks different from our image
of Canada today. I know when you
imagine Canada in your minds,
it's not this picture. And of
course, I'll point out the two
solitudes of English Canada,
French Canada. We were there
too. But can you imagine Canada
with indigenous roots? Well,
part of its indigenous roots
were the Indian act, a federal
act, born in 1870 640 years ago
that
took great measures in
controlling the lives of
indigenous people. These are my
parents, I'm sitting in my dad's
lap, and one of my sisters died
when I was about five years old,
she was accidentally shot to
death by the boy next door. And
I tell that story, because I
knew Even then, even as a five
year old, that communities and
people were meant to be
organized to help each other
that that wasn't supposed to
happen. And my family who was
quite wounded by that deserved
help, and we should be organized
enough to help. So the challenge
for us today in Canada is that
health outcomes between First
Nations and other Canadians is
different. It's unacceptable,
it's unethical. And it's
sustained, unsustainable. And so
what shall we do? Just to point
out Dr. Camara Jones in Undoing
Racism describes, in a gardeners
tale, that a gardener notices
that pink flowers grow taller
than red flowers, and she thinks
pink flowers are better,
forgetting that she's planted
them in different parts of the
garden, one in rich soil, and
one in poor soil. And so we
discussed the the idea of the
social determinants of
indigenous health, that the
quality of health, the quality
of life, the length of life, the
lack of suffering, is tied to
poverty, to education, and to
housing, of course, for all of
us. But for indigenous people.
It's also related to culture,
and to self determination that
the lack of determination can
change one's health. Here are
two Aboriginal medical students
who graduated just a few weeks
ago, in my teaching at UBC, we
discovered that 31 out of 32
Aboriginal medical students had
racist experiences that were
strong enough to discourage them
from continuing. And we had to
talk to them about staying in
their programs. And thus the
idea comes forward. If we're
going to face the inevitability
of a racist experience, perhaps
we should be armed for racist
experiences. And that doesn't
mean that all of you or all of
us are racist, simply that the
reaction, the idea of
resistance, and resilience is
one that we must live with. When
I moved to BC, with my new
medical degree, and I went to
St. Paul's hospital, I went into
the doctor's lounge, I was very
proud, I looked exactly like
this. within five minutes, the
security guard came up to me.
And he said, I'm I'm sorry, sir,
one of the doctors has reported
that there's an Indian in the
doctors lounge. And I laughed,
and I said, Yeah, you better get
used to it. Part of my work is
to work with Aboriginal
populations. One day, we had a
chief who was fighting for the
return of an infant who had
died. The chief coroner said by
law, I'm allowed to keep this
infant body for as long as I see
fit. And I can remove parts of
that body and keep them in order
to determine a cause of death.
And the Chiefs slammed his fist
on the ground or on the table
and said, We know you think
you're in charge. But we think
that's our baby. So to get where
we need to go, we may need to
fly in a different way. I showed
this to an elder. And she said,
Oh, yeah, there's male eagle
flies up down when it is having
sex. And I said, Oh, that's not
quite what I wanted to say. And
she said, Yeah, that's a sexy
Eagle. Thank you.
Rebecca Thomas: Kwe, ni'n
teluisi Rebecca. Hi, my name is
Rebecca. Shall we?
The language you speak
fundamentally shapes your
worldview and everything that
goes along with it. And this
concept is specifically
amplified. When it comes to
indigenous languages. indigenous
language weaves its way through
every aspect of who we are as
people from how we interact with
the physical world, how we build
our communities and how we carry
our culture forward. And with
that comes a unique perspective.
And it's that perspective that
I'm going to try to create for
you so that when I introduce the
concept of etuaptmumk, of
two-eyed seeing, you'll
understand why it's so
important. So to begin, a study
published in psychological
sciences called two languages,
two minds broke down grammatical
tools that situate actions in
time, they showed photographs to
English and German speakers and
asked them to describe what was
going on in them. So for
example, they showed a woman
walking in a parking lot.
English speakers said, this is a
woman walking, whereas German
speaker said this is a woman
walking to her car, they showed
another photograph a man riding
his bicycle. Once again, English
speakers honed in on the action
and said this is a man riding
his bicycle, whereas German
speakers needed to add a
destination to complete their
context, even though that
destination wasn't featured in
the photograph. This is a man
riding his bicycle to the
library or to the supermarket.
And what's interesting thing is
that English marks events as
ongoing, were very action
oriented in our language. So if
I'm writing a poem when my
spouse calls and he asks me what
I'm doing, I'll say I'm writing,
regardless of the fact that I
had stopped to answer the phone.
German simply doesn't have this
feature. And so it's interesting
to see the two worldviews these
languages carry, even though
they have a common root. So what
happens when you have a group of
people with a language that has
no common root but must operate
within a completely foreign
framework? Specifically, how do
indigenous people find success
in a colonized world? Now the
saying things get lost in
translation rings truer than you
might imagine, when it comes to
indigenous languages. This is
Mi'kmaq territory. And many of
you might have heard the word
pjila'si to mean welcome. That's
what it's used for. But the
literal translation of the
concept equates to, I'll do my
best. That's a much more nuanced
and meaningful interaction. In
this moment, a person to person
contract is being agreed upon.
Think about that. In this
moment, I will try for you. So,
language, so language isn't just
something we use to get our
points across. As I said, it's
woven into who we are as people
and our notions of a broader
identity. So Robert Thomas, no
relation wrote about that, that
broader identity, and he called
it peoplehood, when referring to
indigenous peoples. Now, the
term peoplehood is a little bit
odd. So I'm going to break it
down for you, people who have
differs from identity and that
it not only encompasses the
individual identity, but how
that person ties it to a larger
collection of peoples and how
that in turn connects them to
other people within that
collective. So for example, I
don't speak Mi'kmaq, and I grew
up off reserve, but I still
identify as a Mi'kmaq person,
I'm still within the concept of
a Mi'kmaq peoplehood. And that,
in turn, connects me to somebody
who grew up on reserve, and who
speaks the language. And it's
getting a bit complex, so please
bear with me. peoplehood is made
up of four things territory,
sacred history, ceremonial
cycle, and language, each thread
informs the other, you can't
address a single aspect of it
without looking at the whole,
think of a spiderweb. If you
clip a single thread that
anchors it, the whole thing
starts to collapse. So the
Mi'kmaq language, for example,
with its unique characteristics
gives meaning to a sacred
history, which dictates the use
of the land which is crucial to
the appropriate execution of a
ceremonial cycle, which in turn,
is performed in many of the
languages that those ceremonies
encompass. So firstly, that is a
direct quote from my MA. So I'm
going to take this moment and
feel vindicated in my decision
to pursue another arts degree.
And secondly, indigenous peoples
are complicated and complex.
Imagine centuries ago, when we
were writing the treaties and
the language we were
communicating in encompassed,
how we would use the land, how
would we carry our culture
forward? How would we develop
relationships with the settlers
and colonizers, now how much of
that was lost in translation
when they were recorded in
English, and French. So I
digress. But remember those four
strands, language, ceremonial
cycle territory, and sacred
history, the best part about
peoplehood is that it is
tremendously flexible, we can
swap out and alter some of those
strands without compromising our
status as indigenous people. So
once again, I'm going to use my
lived experience as an example,
you already know, I don't speak
mega mom. And that's because
through residential school, my
primary language thread has been
replaced with English and
French. So if I go to a ceremony
that's conducted entirely in the
megamall language, the
significance of that ceremony
might not fully resonate with me
because I want to understand the
full scope of what's being said,
but that does not diminish who I
am as an Mi'kmaq person.
Furthermore, there are many
Mi'kmaq people who are
practicing Catholics. So even
though they smudge and they
dance, and they drum and they
sweat, they also go to church
and pray in the megamall
language and that does not take
away from them they have woven
another set of ceremonies into
their ceremonial threat. Because
being an indigenous person is a
lived experience. It's there's
no spectrum whereby somebody is
more or less native than
somebody else. Any arguments
over authenticity are us
internalizing a history of
colonialism that has created
rubrics and tools to measure our
ethnicity. And blood quantum has
nothing to do with it. The fact
that my mother is non native
does not take away from the fact
that I am Mi'kmaq person.
So with that said, I'm going to
check in with you guys. Language
shapes your worldview, and is
one of four aspects that create
an indigenous people who had an
indigenous understanding of
knowing of how the world works.
So when you look at the picture
that I'm trying to paint for
you, you're going to understand
what you're looking at. So
here's the picture. Indigenous
peoples are the fastest growing
demographic in Canada, our
median age is 28 years old
compared to that a 43, to the
non native world. And what that
means is you're going to see
more of us in your classrooms,
in your workspaces in in your
public spaces, the world is
going to have to learn to
interact with us in ways that
are more meaningful and
significant than what they have
done in the past. I don't need
to elaborate for you all to
know, we don't have the best
history. So what? That's the
question I always get asked, how
does this apply to the real
world, I work in Student
Services in education, I act as
a go between for the native and
non native world, I advocate for
students who have a hard time
speaking up about themselves, I
coach faculty on how to have
appropriate cultural supports.
And yet, in spite of what I try
to do, sometimes the effects and
indigenous student feels are too
great, and they leave to go
home. And it's not that they're
not smart. It's not that they
aren't capable of doing the
work. It's just that this world
doesn't get them. Our protocols
are concepts of time, our
ethics, etc, are just different.
And it doesn't mean we can't
communicate with your world.
We've been doing it for the
better part of five centuries.
It's that we ask that you now
try to communicate with our
world. And it is at this moment
that I introduced the concept of
etuaptmumk of two-eyed seeing it
was introduced the elder Albert
Marshall. Two-eyed seeing tanks
takes the strengths of both a
colonized world and both an
indigenous world and ask that
the user see through both lenses
simultaneously to find success.
It is the magma understanding of
the gift of multiple
perspectives to see multiple
contexts simultaneously. For
example, you see Nova Scotia,
Nouvelle-Écosse, Canada, we see
Mi'kma'ki, traditional
territory, Turtle Island. It's
not either or it's both at the
same time. Two-eyed seeing was
originally introduced to build
greater capacity for STEM
programming for Indigenous
students and post secondary
institutions, and is now being
adopted nationally by
organizations and institutions
who are interested in trans
cultural collaboration two-eyed
seeing implies responsibilities
for reciprocity, mutual
accountability and co learning.
It's what we tried to build our
treaties on. We want you to know
about us and we want success in
this world, but we are no longer
willing to give up our world to
do it. And you might be asking
yourself, why would I go through
so much trouble? To indigenize?
The institution for such a small
number of students in the
answer, my friends, is
beautiful. It has been shown it
has been proven that when
institutions implement
indigenous pedagogy and learning
styles, students across the
board benefit, native and non
native. Because we recognize the
multiple contexts and paradigms
that learners learn through our
ways of teaching have
traditionally been more
universal, and more inclusive.
So
with all of my academic speak,
and concept introduction, I
bring it back to the elders, who
always tend to say it best with
regards to education, and
relationship building. According
to Albert Marshall, the
foundational basis of any
relationship is an exchange of
stories. So as a storyteller,
and as a poet, I will leave you
all with what I do best, a poem
entitled etuaptmumk. I lost my
talk said Rita Jo, for me, I was
never given the option to know
to feel the flow of the words as
they rolled off my tongue,
giving me the lyrics and how our
world was sung. My perspective
was spun using the threads of
both your world and theirs left
to cobble together a spirit from
rags and tears painfully aware
that I was different. through
hard work and determination. I
found my indigenous articulation
a compilation of two ways makes
up the sum of me. You have two
eyes that you only have one view
your way is best you would argue
centuries of being in position
to subdue those who would aspire
they say the sun never set on
the British Empire. And because
we recognize the hubris that
defines your story, we have both
a sunrise and a sunset in our
territory. With my heart and
eyes, I have a completely
different view, the consequence
of my skin comes in an entirely
different hue, don't you see,
although you represent us, we
think very differently than you
because we see the world not
through one set of eyes. But
through to thousands of years
long, we were independent, proud
and strong. We belong to this
earth, the way power belongs to
money and privilege to birth we
put our communities first. But
then came the fleets filled with
those you would ironically
define today as come from a way
to invade every inch of our
world to break our spirits and
pull the threads that would
unfurl us to catch the way you
speak. But this is not a poem
for the retelling of a one sided
history. Each of our worlds has
their strengths. Yours is in
power. It gets to eat its cake
and define race. It has the
ability to unapologetically take
up space. If societal progress
is linear. This society is top
tier Terra nullius, as though we
were never here, it must be nice
to be so confident. This society
is ubiquitous built on rarefied
rubrics of tradition and
rhetoric, your notions of
diversity are ad hoc in nature
and afterthought feature to an
immovable structure. But this is
not a conviction, nor an
acquittal. Just the voice coming
from an eye trained to be
critical. And if you push the
two sides of our Venn diagram
together, you'll get our circle.
We were never meant to be
static. Like the rivers around
us, we shift and change and
remain dynamic, we bring
something to the table that is
able to change your worldview
and show you what we are capable
of that a lot can come from a
holistic concept of the earth,
you are not a flag, nor are we a
curse or a problem in need of a
solution. And we've got to rid
ourselves of the spiritual
resolution, the dilution of our
treaties written to share this
land. And I asked that you
understand that we are the
experts on what we need. Don't
feed us your good intentions
carefully laid apologies will
not get you in historical
exemption, we plan our actions
for the next seven generations.
And we invite you to do the
same. Open your other set of
eyes, take a pause and start
breathing. Welcome to the world
of two-eyed seeing. Thank you.
Wela'lin.
Patricia Saulis: So in terms o
these practitioners, and and t
e two people that we just saw, y
u know, it brings up a lot a
ound what can we learn? What d
we know? How do we learn who c
n benefit? How, how does how w
learn matter. referenced in b
th of these presentations was t
e connection to where they c
me from. The need for sharing s
ories the ability to connect e
periences and lessons learned, t
e richer the opportunity to l
arn from other perspectives t
rough a lens that allows for i
corporating vision and spirit a
d information and to be able t
communicate from that space i
a path to creating balance in d
aling with issues of e
vironmental justice, as I have b
en through the as I have been t
rough the class that I am a g
est lecturer in with Professor P
radis and Jahn, it is allowed a
new door to open to discussing h
w convergence of extraction e
vironmental justice and Media S
udies is powerfully related. N
xt slide please. Recently in o
r comparative Media Studies c
ass, Professor Macarena G
mez-Barris gave a presentation a
d referenced your work the e
tractive zone, which contains t
e following comment. Before t
e colonial project could p
osper, it had to render t
rritories and people's e
tractable and it so through a m
trix of symbolic physical and r
presentational violence. T
erefore, the extractive view s
es territories as commodities, r
ndering land is for the t
king, while also de valorizing t
e hidden world that came from t
at sorry, while also de v
lorizing the hidden world that f
rm the nexus of human and non h
man multiplicity. This v
ewpoint similar to Colonial g
ze facilitates the r
organization of territories, p
pulations and plant and animal l
fe into extractable data and n
tural resources, material and i
material accumulation to white s
eing as a way of creating the s
ace for balance in the s
stemic, systematic approach to e
traction and the creation of w
alth. As acknowledged, and as w
sit here through this p
ndemic, we must open two eyes a
d see, we cannot sustain f
ture generations through w
llful blindness. Next slide p
ease. too wide seeing as r
lated to the media, we have t
e opportunity to create i
novative and meaningful m
ssages of collaboration. T
rough adopting a two-eyed s
eing approach, we can build n
w pathways, protocols, new r
lationships based on respect f
r ourselves and each other. It i
time that we put down the f
ar of not knowing and d
veloping our abilities to i
stinctually know what we need t
create sustainability and e
uality for our young. We can l
arn and grow and accepting the n
ed for systemic change the n
ed for systemic security and w
ll being as impetus for i
novation and research. We can t
uly go within and see the w
rld through clarity and keep m
ving towards holistic well b
ing, we can become teachable. m
dia has a role and a r
sponsibility to informing and a
lowing opportunities to e
ucate and inform about to I'd s
en, it will be worth the e
fort.
Next slide, please.
And in conclusion, there is one
last brief clip that I wanted to
share with you.
Unknown: Welcome to C 2019.
I'm very honored to open this
conference with
a written steam award to elder
Albert Marshall
and his late wife, Murdena
Andy Rowe: Albert, you are my
trusted guide for how I should
look at embrace and also engage
with the world around me,
through you, and through
Murdena, and your writings and
most importantly, your spirit.
We receive guidance and
mentorship, and how to set aside
personal ambitions, to set aside
pain and darkness
and turn to trusting and to
assisting.
Zenda Ofir: I want to thank the
Canadian evaluation Association
for giving me this opportunity
to be part of a tribute to
someone had the wisdom years ago
to understand that we need to
respect and appreciate the
other. And this wisdom is today
more valuable than at any time
as we the people in the world
tend to drift apart at the
moment. And this is exactly the
time where we need to stop for a
moment and look at what combines
us what what we can blend
together to take the best from
all of us, in order to improve
what we do our practice and the
world
Larry Bremner: Two-eyed seeing,
I think really has played an
important role in increasing the
understanding of the indigenous
ways of knowing and doing as
well as indigenous ways of
evaluating by saying that we're
looking at the strengths of the
Western world with one eye and
the strengths of the indigenous
world than other eye, it really
becomes a non threatening way to
engage people in evaluation and
increases their likelihood to
understand that in fact, you can
accept indigenous evaluation
practice, in a way increases the
authenticity of your work.
Glen Page: Two-eye seeing allows
us to better understand the
challenges that we face, working
with organizations and ideas
like blue marble evaluation.
This provides us an important
principle to bring forth to the
world and is with great, great
honor that we celebrate this
work of elder Albert Marshall
and his late wife mardana. On
the work of two-eyed seeing
Michael Quinn Patton: I had the
privilege of engaging with elder
Marshall at the Canadian
evaluation society when we
discussed together rights based
evaluation. And what we found in
that engagement was the two-eyed
seeing in forms all kinds of
evaluation, including the work
that I've been involved in over
the last few years on Blue
Marble evaluation. Blue Marble
refers to looking at the earth,
as a whole, as seen from outer
space, and in our engagement
together through marble
evaluation, and to I'd seen are
completely integrated, as is
integrative science. So what we
have found in blue marble
evaluation and into I'd seen is
the integration of the local and
the global is the integration of
theory and practice is looking
across different sectors and
issues to see their
commonalities is to look across
artificial boundaries of nation
states. So that what we are
empty, attempting to do in
creating a sustainable future,
as to I seen instructs us is to
combine the human and the
natural.
Stephanie Francis: On June 21,
of 2017, I went out to fast. And
I prayed for the spirits of
these women and girls that had
been missing or murdered in New
Brunswick, I prayed for the
spirits of the families that I
would be working with.
And I knew that energy would be
really strong.
And that even though the
victims, they're no longer here
in a physical sense, their
spirits are always with us. And
so I wanted to approach this
project in a good way.
And that meant taking it to
ceremony.
And in terms of evaluation, we
look at how many times we've
gone to ceremony. We talk about
the importance of narratives and
the qualitative the qualitative
feedback from families, not just
the written feedback.
And
and I really owe that to Albert
and Murdena.
They provided me with
some valuable lessons
about how
how important our worldview is
the valid they, they taught me
to value, who I am, and where I
come from, and why I am the way
I am. They taught me how to
value the territory that we come
from
the land, the water,
and even the different ways we
show that appreciation, through
song, through dance, through
painting. And then it doesn't
always have to look like Western
mainstream methods.
And I just want to say thank you
to Albert,
for taking his time and his
energy to pray on these things.
And to be so wise and to share
and to have faith that these
teachings will go on and, and
spread throughout Mother Earth
to everyone.
Patricia Saulis: So, in
conclusion, I just wanted to
close with another quote from
dark Dr. Martin Luther King Jr.
and he said we have flown the
air like birds and swung the sea
like fishes. But we have yet to
learn the simple act of walking
the earth like brothers. Only
when
Scot Osterweil: Thank you. Thank
you very much for that
presentation. Patricia. I have
time for for questions from
clearly.
Anyway, we can switch our view
here. All right.
Jim Paradis: Laura
Scot Osterweil: I'm sorry. We're
seeing hands raised now.
Okay.
I'm sorry, whoever's raised the
hand should feel free to speak.
Laura Partain: Alright, so I
raised my hand but I Just wanted
to ensure first that there
wasn't someone else who is
specifically in indigenous
Canadian and US studies who
would like to ask a question
before me.
Just out of respect?
No. Okay, thank you so much for
this presentation I greatly
appreciated as someone who works
on indigenous communities in the
Middle Eastern and North African
region. So thank you. This was
one wonderful, I have a few
questions. and wondered if you
could clarify just certain
points of the pedagogy that that
this is advocating for. And in
one of the videos, one of the
one of the women, she was
talking about the relevance of
compare and contrast, as an
important way to approach to I'd
seen, and I'm wondering if
compare and contrast,
unconsciously privileges,
Western thought, as an
ontological approach that
indigenous learning is, is
always already measured against?
Or how do you approach or how do
you account for certain inherent
imbalances in, in, in power, due
to suppose rationality of
Western thought, and I just
really am curious about this,
for my own pedagogy, and if you
also have a recommendation for a
repository of this information
for pedagogical thought I would
really appreciate you sharing
that as well.
Patricia Saulis: Will you and
thank you, I think that's an
excellent question. And often
times, you know, folks or folks
are wondering how can we
approach this from, I guess, the
the understanding that both
indigenous knowledge systems and
Western knowledge systems are
legitimate. And so one from the
outset understands, and I guess
we would say appreciates, that
one system is not privileged or
or seen as having higher
authority or claim to
truthfulness, that, that the
other system does not also carry
that. So So I know that, you
know, me saying that doesn't
necessarily address your
question. But I know as far as
getting the understandings and
the teachings directly from, you
know, our elders and, and others
who are practicing too wide
seeing, that is something that
they would reference at the
outset of bringing forward this,
these ideas. And, and I think
it's really important that, you
know, along with understanding
the legitimacy and the place,
and the acceptance of that,
credibility that comes with
appreciating both knowledge
systems is is an important step
for folks to take. Because, you
know, as we know, we've we've
had a very long time of one
system being elevated to to
almost the point of the other
system, completely
disintegrating. And so through
this approach, the idea is that,
through revitalizing indigenous
knowledge systems, we are
providing and creating the space
for balance, essentially,
because it is through that it's
through that exchange, it's
through the reciprocity of, of,
you know, providing ideas and
observations in regards to a
particular,
you know,
purpose or matter that it is in
that is in that cross
pollination of that discussion,
that you really begin to get
the, I guess, the abundance or
the fruitfulness of what that
can bring into a conversation
that is otherwise, you know,
pretty, pretty, pretty set in
terms of what is established
knowledge on the matter. So, and
as far as providing resources. I
do just want to say that, you
know, I have been working with
MIT NASA and MIT AISES for us to
create a reading list Actually,
we, we don't actually have that
as a as a resource. And so we
are going to be doing that. And
as you could probably tell, I
have a lot of references that
I'm compiling already, but we're
working as a as a collective
exercise. So that, you know,
different different levels of,
let's say, audience and
readership, for the younger hip
crowd, and perhaps, you know,
those that are more aware of,
you know, contemporary
references that, that we're
going to have a range of, of
what's available for materials
and and what we can reference.
Scot Osterweil: I have a
question from the chat. But
before I did, I want to open it
up if there's someone and has a
question, among the panelists.
Right, so the question from the
chat is from Perry, it's a
practical question, how can
science writers and science
journalists and reporters
finding digital sources to help
balance their reporting and
bring to it seeing into their
journalism?
Patricia Saulis: Well, there is,
I think, a number of ways. Um,
first and foremost, I would say,
you know, as, as with any kind
of journalistic exercise, you
develop contacts, you develop,
you know, references, I think
taking that time to do some of
that foundational research about
who is available, where you're
at, and the particular matter,
um, you know, is, is one
technique, I think there's
another technique and that is to
actually reach out within MIT to
the indigenous community here,
we have both AISES and NASA that
have, um, you know, student
groups. And, and they are, you
know, always meeting always
interested to have a good
conversation. And so, you know,
if that is more practical to an
amenable to, you know, how
someone can reach out, I'd say,
you know, reach out to, to the
folks you may know, and they can
often provide further contacts
for, for you, depending on
depending on the subject matter.
Scot Osterweil: And we have a
question from Caroline Jones.
Caroline Jones: I, thank you so
much for that really fascinating
talk. Um, and, you know, I'm
thrilled because I helped
through some administrative
funds to support Marisa and
Jim's class. So I'm really glad
that this has been such a
fruitful exchange, I wanted to
know, if you had some
information on how successful
the two-eyed seeing has been, as
a pedagogy, to draw indigenous
peoples into the sciences. You
know, as an MIT faculty member,
it seems like such a vital,
vital part of that pedagogy. And
I also just wanted to make a
recommendation for a book that
I'm sure you know, which to my
way of reading would be on the
top of your reading list, which
is the PhD botanist, Robin Wall
Kimmerer's book, it just changed
my life. So I'm hoping that, you
know, models such as her center
for Native peoples in the
environment, which is drawing
students from all over the US to
do, essentially, maybe even for
the first time, graduate work in
science that they can take back
to their communities and
practice on their ecosystems. It
just feels to me like such a
brilliant example of what you're
talking about.
Patricia Saulis: No, know for
sure. And I really, really
appreciate all your effort and
support. That is wonderful to
hear. And, you know, in terms of
in terms of success, I would say
that you you only have to go as
far as your searchable Google
engine and put in two-eyed
seeing and you will find a
number of both scholarly
articles and other types of
references that will provide at
least foundational material um,
you No, as far as success goes,
I have through my role with the
Maliseet Nation Conservation
Council, we have been working
with Elder Albert, I'd say for
about seven years now. And, and
we have been working to
incorporate two wide seeing into
the work that we do with
communities and with partners.
But as well with government,
and, and it's always so
interesting to find in in
discover where conversations can
go when it's based on this type
of an openness and a willingness
to learn from each other. And
truly, that that's, you know,
difficult as it is that really,
it takes some it takes some
openness to be able to begin to
appreciate what is being, I
guess, explained and described
as a way of communicating with
each other. And that's why, you
know, it's such a wonderful fit,
with CMS and the ability for
especially the students that are
in our class,
to
understand and to be able to
hear the indigenous perspective
on environmental justice and
extraction, and how that
translates into how they use
media and, and media messaging
in order to bring across their
stories, their concepts. And,
and I, you know, must say it's,
it's been a tremendously
positive response, or myself,
even just, you know, in these
last few months, that people are
incredibly receptive, and, and
really quite curious about how
to mobilize and, you know, some
efforts and collaborations that
that really are so wonderful
that I think are really
providing an opportunity for
innovation and creativity, which
is, you know, of course, the
very best that we can do.
Caroline Jones: I hope some
scientists also are listening.
Thank you so much for your
generosity. Woliwon.
Scot Osterweil: Yes, thank you.
Patricia, I don't see other
questions, although if someone
has been Now, last chance, but
this will be this is recorded.
So it will be online. And so
hopefully many more people will
see it as well. Again, we really
thank you for your there is a
question. Oh, good question in
the queue. Yeah, let's go for
that. I'm sorry. I didn't see
that need to read it out. Loud?
Sure. How does two-eyed seeing
deal with contradictory
conclusions? For example, the
indigenous scholar Marlene Brant
Castellano maintains that
indigenous knowledge includes
revelatory knowledge. This
involves the belief in the
supernatural and things like
dreams and visions, which would
not be accepted in scientific
theories. If some indigenous
knowledge holders are
creationists, for example, how
would you I'd seen record in
style with this theory of
evolution.
Patricia Saulis: Well, I think
it's really not the it's really
not the purpose of two-eyed
seeing to reconcile
irreconcilable differences in
viewpoints. I think more so.
Two-eyed seeing is meant to
create the space for a balanced
discussion. And an often times,
you know, folks that are our
field feeling, you know, that
dichotomy and that opposition
and conflict in view, even even
there, even in creating the
space for for those views, to
coalesce, and, and created
dialogue, I think is is part of
the process. And in really
providing that opportunity to
respectfully Listen, and
actually hear what people have
to say. I think I think that is
that is the that is the strength
of too wide seeing is that, you
know, no one, no one is assumed
to be wrong, and no one is
assumed to be right. We all have
something to bring to the
conversation. And let's have it,
let's do it. Let's have that.
Let's have that exchange.
Scot Osterweil: Thank you. Thank
you for that question. I hope I
haven't missed anyone if I have,
by all means. Well, it looks
like as they said, it was a
fascinating car. It was a
fascinating presentation and
generated obviously a lot of
interesting questions. And we'll
be having this headline. So
again, many more people can see
it. So thank you for your for
for this.
Patricia Saulis: Woliwon, thank
you, everyone.